cette semaine rendent au pays vous
propose une randonnée spéciale dans les
zones incendiées du maïdo poursuivre
comment la forêt recolonise les lieux le
sentier support sera celui du vaudeville
qui permet de rejoindre la glacière
depuis la route forestière du gîte des
tamarins
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
750 ha en 2010 2800 hectares soit quatre
fois plus en 2011 le double incendie du
maïdo a fait partir en fumée une bonne
partie de la forêt de la planèze des
hauts sous le vent
au niveau du gîte des tamarins au dessus
de trois bassins le sentier de randonnée
qui conduit jusqu'à la glacière serpente
aujourd'hui entre les troncs calcinés
mais la nature reprend peu à peu ses
droits à l'origine le feu est considéré
comme un phénomène naturel provoquée par
la foudre ou des fois par une éruption
volcanique mais c'est par rapport à la à
l'impact de l'homme en fait donc depuis
l'arrivée de l'homme on a constaté une
une recrudescence et des épisodes de feu
dans cette zone il ya eu un incendie
majeur tous les dix ans en moyenne
depuis depuis avant l'arrivée de l'homme
y en avait mais nous on a des données
depuis par exemple 1970 on a eu voilà
quatre gros incendie jusqu'à jusqu'à
cette date
malgré l'ampleur des dégâts il existe
heureusement de nombreuses zones
abritées qui ont été préservés de l'
incendie des îlots de végétation à forte
valeur écologique c'est poche préserver
pour la plupart se situent dans les
ravines encastré isolés
qui sont du coup encore humide
et il ya aussi des zones qui sont sur
des sommets de crête en fait qui sont la
plupart encastré protéger du vent aussi
ces îlots donc dans la suite de la
reprise de la végétation naturelle
saisie de vous constituer un réservoir
de graines en fait quand le vent ou les
oiseaux vont passer dans ces lots ils
vont pouvoir réensemencer tout l'asin
de façon naturelle ce qui constitue pour
nous un intérêt primordial pour la suite
et pour la reprise de la végétation
naturelle
le ski
le vent joue donc un rôle prépondérant
dans la recolonisation des zones
incendiées à l'instar de celle des
coulées de lave à la différence près que
les coulées sont totalement vierge
tandis que même après le passage d'un
incendie le sol des forêts reste chargé
de matières végétales ce qui n'est pas
toujours une bonne nouvelle la
répétition des incendies est en effet
une aubaine pour la prolifération des
pestes végétales comme l'ajonc d'europe
on a l'exemple d'une espèce la plus
problématique sur le massif qu'on
appelle la jambe d'europe aussi jeune et
d'europe ou épinards aussi en théorie la
jonque d'europe constitue ni un gros
problème dans la reprise de la
végétation d'austère sony puisque c'est
une espèce qui est pire au fil c'est à
dire que ça sa croissance est stimulée
par le feu la stratégie de de l'âge on
sait ça manque de graines dans le sol la
dormance des graines de l'agent est
estimé à peu près 40 ans certes égrène
agents peuvent être là depuis 40 ans et
quand le feu va passer va créer une
action mécanique sur les greens donc
c'est par rapport à la vapeur cette
espèce quand elle va pousser en plus
d'être stimulés par le feu elle va lever
plus vite que les espèces du coin
indigènes et
dans sa croissance elle va créer un un
couvert une ambiance un couvert végétal
très dense
en faisant des efforts et des individus
qui peuvent atteindre 2 à 3 mètres de
haut ce qui fait que ça va créer un
couvert impénétrable à la lumière et
dans cette forêt la prolifération des
espèces exotiques envahissantes est
d'autant plus problématique que le
milieu est l'un des plus riches de lille
le taux d'endémisme est en effet ici de
90% c'est à dire que neuf espèces sur 10
n'existe qu'à la réunion a donc là on a
on a une espèce endémique on avait pas
vu jusqu'à maintenant donc c'est le
petit tamarin des hauts le cousin du
tamarin des hauts ou aux scientifiques
se fera des nuits data est donc cette
espèce c'est une espèce qui il est plus
rare à l'échelle de l'île et à l'échelle
du massif on a une inquiétude
particulière par rapport à cette espèce
au niveau des incendies c'est que c'est
une espèce qui n'a pas pour lesquels on
n'a relevé aucune aucun indice aucun
signe de reprise de végétation après un
incendie le temps ne suffira donc
peut-être pas pour que la forêt retrouve
son aspect d'origine l'intervention
humaine sera sans doute nécessaire pour
préserver les équilibres cette même
intervention humaine qui modifient
durablement les paysages
comme la présence de ce puits qui
rappelle que ce sentier a aussi une
forte valeur historique
longtemps il a été emprunté par les
escales de madame desbassyns qui venait
chercher ici les blocs de glace qu'il
stockait dans ces cavités la plus
importante d'entre elles on a gardé le
nom la glacière
ce qui me plaît le plus dans cette
randonnée c'est c'est le contraste entre
les végétation indigène préserver et une
végétation morcelé par les incendies et
puis cette ambiance qui règne tout nous
tout le long du sentier la végétation
brûlée créer une ambiance
à la fois triste mais il ya aussi le
contraste avec l'espoir finalement
puisqu'on à une reprise des des petits
des petits branler des petits camarades
il se trouve ça assez assez exceptionnel
ce que j'aime tout particulièrement
c'est le on ressent l'héritage culturel
qui assure cette zone
historiquement cette zone a été très
visité par le marronnage par l'esclavagé
ce que je n'aime pas sur ce sentier
c'est la structure rocailleuse
du sol en fait qui où on a des qui au
fil de la randonnée est très épuisant
très très contraignant en fait ça peut
être aussi accessibles à n'importe quel
public il faut par contre rester assez
prudent assez vigilants puisque il ya
des endroits qui sont quand même assez
délicat à franchir